[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا قبل ان اتابع تطورات الوضع
السوداني ساشير الى هذا العاجل الذي يرد
الان رويترز اشتعال النار بطائره تابعه
خلال اقلاعها من عاصمه نيبال وتحاول الان
الهبوط اذا
طائره مدنيه تعود لفلاي دبي
تشتعل النيران فيها
فور اقلاعها من عاصمه النيبال وتحاول الان
الهبوط والعوده الى المدرج مجددا
[موسيقى]
اذا بحسب المعلومات الوارده الان الطائره
التابعه لشركه فلاي دبي وطبعا طيران
الامارات تحاول اما الهبوط في مطار
نيودلهي او العوده الى العاصمه الناتبال
لا معلومات حتى الساعه عن سبب الحريق ولا
عن اذا ما كان يعني سيكون الهبوط امن على
امل ان يكون امن طبعا هذه الصور الاوليه
والفيديو الاولي الذي نشاهده عن عمليه
اشتعال النيران بهذه الطائره التابعه
لفلاي دبي والتي طبعا تتبع لطيران
الامارات
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات